it's tough being a teenager at the best
of times
during the pandemic it's so much worse
homeschooling
no hanging out with friends massive
stress
all because of covid19 in fact
more and more young people are getting
infected in germany the number of cases
among teens rose 11
adolescents have until recently been
tested less because they aren't as
impacted by the virus
but they could be asymptomatic carriers
recent outbreaks have been linked to
them spreading the virus
doctors say vaccinations for kids are
key to achieve the levels of immunity we
need in our community
welcome to our kobit 19 special i'm
monica jones and
like millions others i'm still waiting
for my shot
now the good news is worldwide more than
a billion doses have by now been
administered
and teenagers in the united states have
a clear advantage
those aged 16 and up can now receive the
biontech
pfizer shot and anyone 18 and up can get
the moderna shop
for all of them this means the days of
isolation
are soon over
daily training during the pandemic
that's how these two brothers have
gotten through the last months
both will soon get vaccinated the us has
promised teenagers a jab
in the near future being that age is
hard enough
with the covert restrictions it has been
even more challenging
i think for me it's a mental health and
of course like schools i think
some i was worried like they're being
back because they're not going to school
they're behind but i think they're ways
to catch up with academics
but with growth and socialization
you know it's it that's harder school
has been moved into the living room the
boys
can't wait to get their vacci
so it keeps the people my people around
me safer
and i don't keep myself safe too
the vaccine would bring a little
normality back
i don't miss school exactly by the
people in school
because you know it it's really
difficult not to interact people and to
talk to people
and um yeah i mean he's an awesome guy
but he's just my brother
he's not a friend for them
an additional obstacle masks
it's very hard to see people's
expressions and
it just it gives a sense of like
you're talking to a wall or
it's just an audio audiobook
the us is quick with vaccinations but
what if as in other countries
restrictions remained
it would definitely uh reduce like my
social skills
i'm really like not really not the most
social outgoing person
but i think that would
not really be good for me that's why i'm
trying to
go back to school lucy brown is a social
worker
and sees a huge opportunity in teenage
vaccination teens
need to be with their peers and need to
be taking social risks
and doing things on their own
outside of the confines of their family
home for a teenager to have the
opportunity to be vaccinated i think is
tremendous to give them that freedom to
move about
with a lot more confidence for both
themselves and for their parents that
they can
go about their lives and do the things
that they're developmentally
supposed to be doing right now outside
of the us most teenagers
don't have access to the vaccine yet
they have to find other ways
to keep going
so the question is how long until young
people can be vaccinated on a grand
scale
let's ask rolf hemke he's science
communicator of
the german association of research-based
pharmaceutical companies that's the
vfa good to have you with us now as you
know case numbers among young people are
rising here in germany the number of
new cases among teenagers actually now
equals those of older people of over 60
and as far as i know there's no vaccine
inside for the younger age group is
there
that's good news one company has applied
for approval for its vaccine
for adolescents so it seems we are only
weeks away from an approved vaccine for
this
age group also some other companies
are developing their vaccines for this
age group and even for younger children
so most likely within the next months
this year we will get four more
vaccines which are approved for this age
well that is good news indeed but i
wonder why can't we just use the
existing vaccines on teenagers just like
they
now do in the united states we need not
change anything
in the composition it's all about safety
so we can use those vaccines
when we know that it's safe to use them
in
this age group also with children
we can use the same vaccines but we need
to know
what is the good appropriate dosing
so so what are the risks that we know
about for teenagers and children getting
vaccinated
well most likely the risks will be no
other than for adults
well this is something we need to know
and that's why
clinical trials are made with
various age groups to see if the risks
indeed are low and the benefit is high
now of course this takes time i mean you
say we're just weeks away from at least
one vaccine for children which is
brilliant in the meantime however do
those
risks outweigh the risk of of catching
the virus
which as we know by now can lead to
severe inflammatory reactions in
children
known as pims or also long covet
well that's what trials are for they are
designed so that you see that indeed
vaccines are safe and once they are
approved you can
offer them to
to parents and their children
with
confirmed safety and who is actually
investing in vaccine trials for children
well all the companies that have
far developed vaccines for covit 19
they invest in such trials right from
the start they expected to develop the
vaccines
for all age groups and the eu
also expects company to do so you just
mentioned earlier
and i have to get back to that because
that is good news indeed
that we may have a vaccine ready for
children in just a few weeks from now
and there are several other trials
underway
will this vaccine only be available for
children here in europe
are we talking about a vaccine for kids
all over the world
these vaccine trials that are have been
carried out are just being carried out
they will lead to safety and efficacy
data
which can be used all over the world to
apply for approval
and that's what the companies have in
mind also the chinese companies
which have developed vaccines they have
also
included children in their trials so
that they as well
can offer vaccines that are suitable
for children so hopefully
within the next months we will get a set
of
vaccines that are approved to all age
groups
and then it's to politics and to
logistics
to get them out to every child in the
world
all right well let's hope that politics
and logistics are not getting in the way
to get everybody vaccinated royal film
from the german association of
research-based pharmaceutical companies
thank you so much for your time
thank you so vaccination is
one way to train our immune system
against the virus
another is catching it and recover again
but does this always work time to ask
derek
[Music]
do asymptomatic people develop weaker
immune responses
than people who have more severe disease
okay this is going to get probably
horrendously complicated because
we're still so far from unraveling
the immune system which which
immunologists compare to
to a ball of spaghetti which is a really
brilliant image even understanding
just why some people can be infected
yet show no symptoms is a really
complicated task early in the pandemic
studies that focused on antibody levels
in
patients and former patients indicated
that people who got
severe cases of covid19
might have longer lasting immune
responses
and that asymptomatic people might be at
more risk
of getting the disease again at some
point but
but antibody levels are just one aspect
of immune response a recently published
study has now
helped fill in some of the other gaps
it looked at blood samples taken from
several hundred
male migrant workers in singapore who
lived in
densely inhabited dormitories during an
outbreak there
last spring and its findings agree with
other research in one sense
that levels of some antibodies against
covet 19
in the men who got it asymptomatically
did indeed fall more after convalescence
than in those who had symptoms other
immune responses however
including ones involving what are known
as t cells
they remained fairly robust even in the
asymptomatic
group and and that's being carefully
interpreted
as a sign that immunity might
generally remain strong for some time
even in people who caught the disease
but had no symptoms
so so lots of ifs ands
and buts like i said
it's complicated
[Music]
now talking of complicated the
relationship between the eu and
astrazeneca is anything but
easy the european commission has just
announced it's launched legal action
against the british swedish drug maker
for not respecting its contract for the
supply of cobit 19 vaccines
180 million vaccine doses were agreed
for the second quarter of this year
but astrazeneca said it would aim to
deliver only one-third of that to the
block
rastella kiriakides the european
commissioner for health and food safety
explained the decision on twitter saying
every vaccine dose counts
every vaccine dose saves lives
and that's all for this edition thanks
for watching
you